whether the characters are superheroes
super villains or perfectly normal
people caught in the crossfire
what follows are some of the most
memorable superhero movie deaths
ever to darken the big screen tom
hiddleston's portrayal of thor's
adoptive brother loki
is one of the mcu's unquestionable
successes
as the trickster god whose allegiances
seem to change from film to film
loki has proven one of the most popular
characters in the mcu
whether he's working with or against
thor and the other heroes that's part of
why his death in the opening scene of
2018's avengers infinity war proved
not only memorable but shocking what
really makes loki's death so surprising
is the manner of his death
[Music]
when thanos literally chokes the life
out of his former herald
it's one of the most brutal moments in
the infinity saga we saw him die
twice before in the movies but neither
of those fake outs came close to the
ugliness of watching the mad titan
calmly
and easily ring the last breaths from
the god of mischief
there were plenty of different theories
about how loki wasn't really dead
between the announcement he would get
his own disney plus mini-series and the
character's history of fooling his
brother into thinking he was dead
it was an understandable reaction but by
the end of avengers end game
the truth was clear while we would
eventually become acquainted with a
version of the character from a parallel
timeline
loki hadn't escaped anything clark
gregg's portrayal of phil coulson
agent of shield was one of the first
things that made the mcu more than just
a collection of disparate superhero
movies
he was there in the beginning trying to
get an appointment with tony stark in
2008's iron man
he was there to make sure stark didn't
leave his house in the 2010 follow-up
iron man 2
and he mistook the destroyer for one of
stark's inventions
in thor that's why it's such a blow when
loki runs him through in 2012's the
avengers
i don't think
[Music]
so that's what it does colson was a big
part of the glue that held the phase one
films together
and throughout his appearances the
polite level-headed agent
won over fans hearts no one wanted to
see him be one of loki's victims
which sadly made him the perfect choice
as the sacrificial lamp
that caused the team to finally start
acting like a team
of course the avengers wasn't the end
for coulson it wasn't even the last
death he'd come back from
he returned from the land of the dead
for marvel's agents of shield
and he suffered death and more rebirth
on that show as well
still those resurrections don't make his
death at loki's hands any less powerful
in a way it renders it even more tragic
when you finally learn
on agents of shield how traumatic his
resurrection proves to be
the murder of thomas and martha wayne
has become one of the darkest moments of
popular culture
whether it's from 1989's batman 2005's
batman begins
2016's dawn of justice or 2019's joker
it's a scene that's as necessary as it
is tragic
the details aren't always the same in
batman for example they're coming out of
a viewing of the mask of zorro
while in batman begins they're leaving
an opera early because young bruce wayne
freaks
out over cast members dressed as
monstrous bats
don't be afraid
[Music]
in batman it's a younger jack napier who
murders the wanes
while in other versions it's either joe
chill or nameless criminals
like the clown masked murderer at the
end of joker but the important details
are always the same
the scene always ends with bruce wayne's
parents stolen from him
and with a young boy finding himself at
the beginning of a path that ends with
him becoming one of the most
recognizable superheroes of
all time regardless of the movie or who
pulls the trigger
batman is born in crime alley
in a movie filled with superheroes
biting the dust
one death hits harder than most after
thanos finally assembles all six
infinity stones in avengers infinity war
and makes his fateful snap half the
universe's living beings die
including a lot of costumed heroes along
with taking out a huge chunk of the
avengers
thanos's snap kills all the guardians of
the galaxy
except rocket and nebula peter parker's
chilling words to tony stark are still
some of the hardest for us to hear
[Music]
i don't feel so good it seems like most
audience members
knew there was no way parker's death
wouldn't be reversed
not to mention the deaths of most of the
other heroes avengers infinity war was
holland's third appearance as spider-man
and the consensus was fans loved this
version of the webslinger there was no
way marvel would end holland's time as
spidey so abruptly
regardless when you re-watch the scene
you still hear the fear in parker's
voice
and you feel the helpless desperation in
stark along with his guilt for bringing
such a young boy into this dangerous
world of interstellar mad men
you can resurrect parker a dozen more
times and it won't make this sad death
on titan any less heartbreaking
it's surprising how unforgettable the
deaths of howard and maria stark are in
2016's captain america civil war
after all they're dead at the start of
the very first mcu film
iron man but it's the manner of their
death as well as the identity of the
killer
that makes the scene so powerful in
2014's captain america the winter
soldier
we learned that the deaths of tony
stark's parents while officially deemed
the result of a car accident
were hydra ordered assassinations the
revelation comes courtesy of the a.i
arnhem zola and we don't get many
details until the sequel
in civil war we learned the starks were
assassinated while transporting new
batches of the super soldier formula to
shield
the brainwashed winter soldier forced
them off the road
and finished them both off with his bare
hands watching the scene and seeing the
winter soldier's cold brutality
it's really not surprising that zemo
correctly guesses that iron man would do
everything he could to kill bucky
whether he was reformed or not it wasn't
him tony
hydra had control of his mind move it
wasn't yet in 2016's dr strange
the titular hero's mentor the ancient
one
proves to be much more deeply flawed
than she initially appears
in spite of the loyalty she inspires and
the practitioners of camartage
we eventually learn the sorcerer supreme
has been breaking her own rules in order
to fight back the forces of darkness
by tapping into the power of the dark
dimension to prolong her life
and help keep mystic threats at bay it's
a betrayal that inspires casilius and
his followers to wage
war on camartage as well as eventually
convincing mordo to walk a different
path
the ancient one's death is no less
affecting for these revelations
when stephen strange assumes his astral
form to follow the ancient one's spirit
to the exterior of the hospital
she tells her student the reasons for
her dishonesty as well as revealing that
she's seen her death and visions
it's a quietly powerful moment the
ancient one uses her last words to admit
to strange that she isn't prepared for
death
look at me stretching one moment out
into a thousand
just so that i can watch the snow and
then she's gone
in the final cataclysmic battle of
avengers endgame
thanos means to destroy the entire
universe and everyone in it
all in favor of a new reality filled
with servile beings being grateful for
thanos's vision
but instead of the mad titan snapping
his fingers it's tony stark who delivers
the decisive blow to thanos and his
armies
during their fight tony grapples with
thanos and he lets the villains think
he's beaten him when
in reality stark steals the infinity
stones back
so when thanos triumphantly declares i
am
inevitable and snaps his fingers nothing
happens
[Music]
iron man they're the words 2008's iron
man
ends with and now they're tony stark's
final words as well
he snaps his fingers and lives long
enough to see thanos and his alien
armies turn to dust
sadly tony knows using the stones will
be the last thing he ever does
only someone of tremendous physical
power can use the stones and survive
peter parker and roadie give tony their
tearful goodbyes
and his wife pepper has to say goodbye
you can wrestle for the first decade of
its existence
robert downey jr's amazing portrayal of
tony stark was the heart and soul of the
mcu
his final scene could never be anything
but heartbreaking
when wade wilson's would-be victim
sergey turns up at the mercenaries
apartment in 2018's deadpool 2
he seems mostly to want to kill deadpool
but instead
his bullets hit and kill wade's main
squeeze vanessa
it's a tough death to handle so early in
the film particularly since vanessa is
the same woman wade pines over
and risks everything to save in the
first movie vanessa's death sends wade
spiraling towards self-destruction
a self-destruction that would be much
more literal if he didn't heal
himself from everything including
blowing his own body to pieces
it also leads to one of deadpool 2's
most brilliant moments
after catching up to vanessa's killer
wade embraces him
fooling us into believing that wilson is
going to spare him
that is until wade steps into traffic
while hugging his victim
killing sergey and making his first in a
series of feudal attempts at
guilt-ridden self-destruction
it's the most humorless moment in the
film and it's absolutely perfect
thankfully vanessa is one of the lucky
people wade saves with cable's time
travel device in a mid-credit scene
which he balances by killing two
different versions of himself
the deadpool of 2009's x-men origins
wolverine and the one who wrote the
script for 2011's green lantern
in 2008's the dark knight one of the
deepest wounds joker makes is the murder
of bruce wayne's old friend rachel
convinced batman and the cops won't have
enough time to save both of them
joker reveals the separate locations
where he's keeping rachel and harvey
dent hostage amidst large amounts of
explosives
but the clown prince of crime isn't
completely honest
correctly predicting batman will
prioritize saving rachel
he lies about which hostage is at which
location
instead of rachel batman finds harvey
dent and
in the meantime the gotham pd isn't fast
enough to get to rachel
then the bomb explodes killing rachel
one small but desperately important
detail about the scene that helps make
it so powerful is the timing
when it comes to our heroes if they're
going to die we usually expect their
deaths to be portrayed as something with
great ceremony
and sentimentality the good guys always
get just enough time to give us their
final noble words
but in rachel's case her death cuts her
off mid-sentence
it's merciless and leaves us shaken
harvey it's okay
it's all right listen
wolverine isn't the only mutant hero we
say goodbye to in 2017's logan
his clone murders logan's old friend and
mentor professor x
and caliban sacrifices himself to help
stop the reavers
but it's the memory of logan's death at
the end of the movie
after he helps save laura and her
friends from the reavers
that inspires the most tears after an
unnaturally long
and hard life logan finally succumbs to
his injuries
the adamantium in his blood has poisoned
him destroying his mutant ability to
heal himself from the horrible wounds
his clone inflicts upon him
as he's dying logan seems almost
grateful to finally feel what it's like
to die
he uses his last words to warn laura to
not go down the same path he did
don't be like that you can argue back
and forth about what logan means for the
x-men movie continuity but its sad
ending feels like the only possible way
to conclude the story of marvel's
hardened
grizzled warrior logan is as bleak and
beautiful as any western and its hero's
noble death gives him a well-deserved
rest after literally
centuries of war check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one